-All right!
All right!
All right.
We're having a good time.
Okay.
I just got a new TV recently,
and I wanted to get
rid of the old one,
but I didn't want to
throw it away,
so I decided I would take it
to Goodwill, right?
And I showed up at Goodwill
with this old TV,
and the Goodwill guy
was like, "Nah."
[ Light laughter ]
He said, "We don't take TVs
like that anymore."
But they did take it.
Later that night
when they were closed.
[ Laughter ]
Know what I mean?
I'm not getting rejected
from Goodwill
is what I'm telling you.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't get my receipt,
though,
so I won't be able to claim that
on my taxes.
So that'll be a tough year.
[ Laughter ]
You ever do that?
You drop off a bag of clothes
at Goodwill and they're like,
"You want a receipt for that?"
I'm like,
"Nah, I don't want proof
I ever owned these clothes."
[ Laughter ]
It's like,
"You see what I'm wearing.
Imagine what I'm giving away
for free."
You know what I mean?
All right. Okay.
[ Applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Hi, hi. Thank you.
I like to wave like this.
I do this a lot.
I like to wave like this
at the end of a joke.
Just let you know
that joke's over.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. All right.
Okay.
All right.
I like to get picture frames
at Goodwill.
Sometimes you get a good deal
on a frame in there.
And sometimes you can
get pictures
of other people's family
in there.
I don't know
how that happens.
People are like,
"Well, I'm done with this frame
and this family."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
"Yeah, they mean a lot to me,
but not enough
to bend a staple in the back."
[ Laughter ]
"Just don't have
that kind of time."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. All right.
Okay.
[ Applause ]
I got this hat at Goodwill.
This hat changes me.
A lot of people don't know
that it changes me,
'cause you haven't seen me
without it on, right?
But if I take this hat off,
you're like, "Oh, man,
I bet that guy likes rock music
right there."
If I put this hat on,
you're like,
"Nah, he's got
a rock collection."
[ Laughter ]
Know what I mean?
Okay. All right.
We're having a good time.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
If I take this hat off,
you're like,
"Man, that guy looks like
the lead singer
from the rock band Korn."
[ Laughter ]
If I put this hat on, you're
like, "Nah, he grows corn."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Okay. All right.
If I take this hat off,
you're like,
"Man, I bet that guy
smokes weed right there."
Mm-hmm.
And I put this hat on,
you're like, "Nah, that guy
definitely smokes weed."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
[ Applause ]
This hat can't change
everything.
You know, it's not a magic hat.
How many people thought my hair
was attached to this hat?
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A lot of people think that.
A lot of times, people tell me
I look like Forrest Gump
after he ran for a long time.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Okay. All right.
I went to someone's house
the other day
and they asked me to take
my shoes off
before I came inside.
And I hate that, you know?
Show up at somebody's house,
they're like,
"Hey, come on in.
You mind taking off your shoes?"
I'm like,
"Nah, I'll just go home."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
That's right.
I went to this flea market
the other day,
and I love a good flea market.
And I was in there, and
this lady had this great deal
on DVDs, right?
She had three DVDs for $5.
And that's a great deal.
So I was like, "I'm going to go
ahead and get six of these,
that way I can get six for $10."
You know?
Three for $5 two times,
right?
[ Laughter ]
Pretty easy, right?
This lady couldn't understand
her own deal, right?
[ Laughter ]
I went up to her,
I was like,
"Hey, I'd like to get
these DVDs."
She goes,
"How many you got there?"
I said six.
She said, "You know it's three
for $5, right?"
I was like,
"Yeah, six for $10."
She goes, "Well, I guess."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
I was like,
"Nah, this is your deal.
This is just three for $5
two times, right?"
So I figure it's settled,
right?
I figure now I'm getting it
for 10 bucks, right?
Then I hear her back there
doing math.
[ Laughter ]
She's going...
[ Imitates whispering ]
She closes her eyes.
She goes,
"All right, that will be $15."
I was like, "Listen,
I'm not even trying
"to bargain with you right now.
This is your deal."
[ Laughter ]
"This is just three for $5
two times.
"You want,
I'll buy these three,
and then I'll
take off this hat..."
[ Laughter, applause ]
All right.
Hey, thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my God!
Oh, that's what I'm talking...
Dusty -- Dusty Slay!
[ Cheering ]
For more, check out
dustyslay.com.